hey guys I'm just McDonald eighties the
28th the februari and that makes it a
Friday and Fridays when I bring you my
top five favorite stories of the week
and we try to get over all the bad jerks
I've made throughout GS news in the week
let's go first up sony might be
announcing a ps4 virtual reality headset
at GBC this year a source told TechRadar
that Sony's oculus rift competitor is
extremely polished and set to impress
the headset is supposedly tailored for
the gaming experience and missed it's
rumored announce date of August
September of last year as a result of
Sony wanting to refine the device before
it goes public do you want virtual
reality to be a bigger part of the way
you game let me know I've got to Japan
related stories today which is absurd
but the first is that Japan have finally
gotten themselves the ps4 for an
equivalent of 390 american dollars the
ps4 is now available to anyone and
everyone who can find one in japan that
means the console is now available in 49
countries so now there are 49 countries
worth of gamers trying to find the store
that actually still has stock left of
the things my second japani story of the
day is that Ubisoft it's sort of
disappointed everybody by saying that
Assassin's Creed five or whatever
they're going to call it will not occur
in Japan feudal Japan may be a fan
favorite location for the series to head
to next but Ubisoft have said it's not
happening what we do know is that the
new location is apparently the same as
Ubisoft Toronto boss Jade Ramon's
favorite historical era I have no idea
what to do with that information
Peter Molyneux may not be as
entertaining as his twisted dwelling
Molly to parody bunny can be equally as
shocking this week he called fable three
a train wreck which is a heavy word for
a reviewer to youth let alone the
creator of the very game he's cursing
speaking about the series Mon you said
fable one was hugely flawed but not bad
given it was his first attempt and then
able to with a step in the right
direction apparently as explained by
that whole trainwreck remark he didn't
see that progress dip into fable 3 and
wish she had an extra 12 months
development times are you a fan of the
fable series and which is your favorite
installment let me know in the comments
metal gear solid ground zeroes has had
quite a bit of controversy over being
short and expensive but the deal is
definitely getting sweeter not only did
Konami drop the price for the xbox one
and ps4 versions of the title but you'll
also be able to get the dlc for the
phantom pain if you buy ground zeroes
the phantom pain isn't due out till 2015
and apparently this is only a
promotional edition available in the
first batch of granser as retail copies
and for a limited period for the digital
version the DLC supposedly gives Metal
Gear players an edge whatever that means
and revolves around resources for a
mother base which apparently plays a
large role in phantom pain they mean are
your thoughts on any or all of today's
stories by riding me a comment in the
comment box on youtube or games but or
you can write to me on my twitter where
i'm at jeff mcdonald this week on site
you should check out our brand new live
show the lobby if you haven't already
tune into some heavy stealing escapades
on GTA diaries or join me on my other
show the gist where I talk about things
we could all use Titans for that's it
for all the things that I wanted to tell
you about this week but be sure to have
a wonderful weekend and I will be back
on your internet screen with more news
on Monday